now if I berserk
it's risky against
a higher rated opponent
you know it's also risky wait what is G3
and G3 can I play D5
this is already new territory
like E4 G3 I think it's an attempt to
play a king's Indian attack
but
allows for this move order
yeah I guess it's still playable
Queen D5
yeah
because Bishop G2 I have F5
I'm trying to punish this opening like
right away
we might see this move
and then I have to be careful because
this is already a threat
yeah maybe I should have
been aware of this
is this hmm
angle play C6
Bishop G2 is coming
wait I do have F5 here
F5 there's a trade
maybe it's okay
F5 Queen H5
I think F5 is okay
so Knight D6 is a move
and if I take those takes
it's very confusing
um
yeah there's a few weird lines like
Knight G6 I just take with Bishop we
trade and then C6 should be okay
there's also a line Knight G5 and I have
to take the queen
take some ambition C8 defending the
bishop and the pawn
and the threat would be H6 there
should also be okay
and there's another line Queen H5 which
I was trying to make sense of
because Queen H5 g6ers
wait there's Knight F6
takes takes takes takes
and then C6 takes here and maybe I trap
the bishop later
but we're going into this line okay
on develop
oh there's this move though
let's move I have Bishop D5
I guess all three captures are possible
okay
realizing I'm not actually threatening
this
because Bishop H5
but maybe I'm fighting this or this
and what a weird opening
um
H6 Knight F7
Rook H7
and then 95. so I have to play 96 here
not super Pleasant
yeah it's one of these weird situations
but you are super Pleasant Eric oh thank
you that was very Timely
I feel like donuts always has very
timely resub messages
out of this move and then King C7
um the king can also come to F6 but
through the power of friendship all
things are possible
oh yes my friendship
through the power of berserking a
flagging becomes more possible
I really have to watch my time
also thank you Kung Fu chess
a nice Kung Fu quote
why are my Knights on the edge
lights are so out of it
but this night ready to come in
I have to rely on intuition at this
point
Bishop D7
Rook is tied down to the pawn
maybe Knight G4 at the right moment
whoa It's Kavita gifting 100 subs thank
you Kavita
that's a big wake up
thanks so much I really appreciate that
I just lose upon oh no my Pawn
the very poisonous looking Pawn
if you were just gifted a sub
you can say thank you
I really appreciate the the energy boost
you have a least favorite opening
um I'll answer that in just a moment
four is a a move
man I'm so bedazzled right now
that's a hard question to answer because
there's so much positive energy
I can't think of anything that's like
least favorite
let's play Knights
Knight C5
okay expanding
in this move is coming and then D4
maybe G6
thank you white noise
a UA rune
I appreciate the hype
yeah let's play G6
the Knight wants to find a new home
oh yeah I mentioned earlier in the
Stream I will be playing Reykjavik open
again this year
I'm really excited to come back
it's it's one of the nicest open
tournaments in the world
um I should have a command for it I'll
work on
finding the official websites
but for anyone that wants more
information you can Google Reykjavik
open
oh
am I in trouble I have this move
take take
maybe it's still okay
actually maybe this move
a little bit safer
a level 12 hype train
oh dear okay wait let me let me Focus
here
I have less than a minute
playing a good player
Knight wants to come back I'll be okay
playing rookie eight
Don't Hurt Me Maybe C5 first
shutting down the bishop
whoa kafita gifting another 100 Subs
also oh no my Bishop
thanks so much Kavita
that's super super kind
I'm in big trouble I'm so flabbergasted
[Music]
um
yeah I'm losing The Rook
it's still playable though
this move
like the biggest concern is time
and position
each five
okay
something
um apply this
I'm trying to say focused
I just missed no after three a three
almost works
hmm
Bishop wants to come here
foreign
position here
I promise time
okay that's a nice gift
another
wow another 50 from Andrew thanks so
much
foreign
[Music]
Connect Four coming
oh no my queen
okay
oh man what a crazy game
oh
well it came
I don't know what just happened there